[Musique]
en France représente une part importante
du groupe et leur mantighton dans le
monde
la France a de vrais atouts dans
différentes industries mondiales
[Musique]
l'automobile l'aérospatiale et d'autres
secteurs
ce centre de R&D est situé dans cette
zone d'innovation et de technologie
nous pouvons donc travailler étroitement
avec ses clients
[Applaudissements]
dans le monde
au début de la pandémie nous avons
décidé que l'élément le plus important
pour et leurs mind title et de se
focaliser sur l'innovation et maintenant
cette investissement montre que nous
continuons à investir et à supporter
l'innovation et la technologie pour la
France et pour les sites en Europe et
dans le monde
cet investissement nous assure la
possibilité de fournir des solutions
innovantes
et nouvelle pour rester au dessus des
autres entreprises
une des spécificités c'est LA CHAMBRE
BLANCHE des environnements sains dans
laquelle nous pouvons développer des
solutions
c'est le cas pour l'industrie médicale
et agroalimentaire où vous avez besoin
de haut niveau de qualité
c'est ce qui va contribuer au succès du
groupe dans le monde entier
[Musique]